[Music]
hello Dancing with the Stars and Heather
Morris fans look who's joining me here
to recap last night's out of Heather
thank you for being here yes of course I
have so many so many questions for you
thank you for being happy to be here
we're so happy to have you here and so
sad you're not on the show anymore but
we'll dive into it I know guys I'm sure
you have a million questions for Heather
so leave them on EPS Facebook page right
now we're going to catch up with her and
also talk about last night's episode
with a double-elimination Cameron
Mathison could not be here today he has
another commitment we miss him but we
have a very gorgeous and wonderful guest
in his place so Heather let's dive in
how has it been it's been about one week
since you're not on the show anymore how
was it watching last night not being
part of it you know I was I was saying
earlier that it was like it just felt
like I was watching the show as if I was
never on it you know like I was just i
watch a lot of reality television so for
me I just like sat back with my husband
and we just kind of watched it like it
was like you know I was being a home
viewer and it's like I do this every
week so you know I got really into it it
felt like I got to know people that I
knew behind camera off camera you know
in a different perspective just seeing
them you know as a viewer so it was cool
you know it's fun to watch them and just
like not have to go up there and perform
and just like sit back and be like okay
I can relax and houses you know dance my
butt off so that was that was really
nice it was nice to watch everybody on
the show and get to see their their
faces again you have been not only so
talented but I think so elegant in the
way that you were on the show and
getting to see your beautiful family and
in the way that you did end up getting
eliminated well yeah we were all
watching thinking me and this this feels
unfair she's eliminated after a perfect
score actually you know let's go out if
we can and play just a little bit of
sound from that elimination moment
because the level of booze in the
auditorium in the on the stage were
crazy here's the moment that has the
rushes yet you guys I don't know no okay
well here we go after a perfect score as
the
and Mack
[Applause]
so you hadn't watched that yet how did
that watching that you know I was always
wondering I was like did my fate you
know like did I make an awful face
because I didn't know what I looked like
if I was like super disappointed I just
knew in the moment like I didn't really
know what's happening but you know it
was good to see you know people were
really supportive of it and we're you
know just as shocked as everybody else
so watching it you know I I just I
recalled the feeling of what it felt
like and it was just you know it was it
was okay I wasn't I wasn't showing too
much emotions like where I was just like
oh god did I make an ugly face or
something so that's good I'm happy about
that
was that something that you had to get
used to because your past was in
scripted TV and then on these reality
shows especially the number of cameras
they have everywhere in the ball yeah
did you have to get used to being Ahnold
and yes it's it's insane you know you
have a camera on you I mean a mic on you
all the time
and there's cameras following you around
so at first you're just like oh my god I
literally can't say anything because
you're afraid you know of whatever
somebody would just you know you look
clip and it would just be used in the
wrong context content context but yeah
it was it was very weird and very hard
to get used to and that night when you
guys were sent home I mean the boos were
audible for viewers at home how loud
were they in the ballroom because Tom
even said I think he said he'd never
heard an audience reaction to an
elimination like I was freaking out it
was like you know it was it was very
audible I think everybody could hear it
how did that make you feel because as I
said you were so poised and so elegant
with getting what felt like very unfair
news what was going through your mind
and how are you feeling about it a week
later yeah it was great I had my friends
in the audience like a lot of my really
close friends that I had grown up with
and that was really really awesome for
them to be there with me I got to share
that with them you know it just felt
like it was home for them being in the
audience you know not just like the
feeling of being alone and having my
husband there it was just like I had
that support of like you know looking
forward to having you know a dinner to
go to with my friends and just talk
about it and kind of get it out the
right way instead of just like dealing
with it by myself so it kind of had that
like full circle of like I have
everybody around me that I love and I
love to share this these moments with
them they know what's real they know
like
you know what's important so that was
kind of just like the moment that I was
thinking about the whole time yeah your
husband I mean I pained me when they cut
to his face in the crowd he just seems
so I know was it I know yeah yeah people
were talking about that afterwards like
you know cutting to your husband was
just like the most heartbreaking moment
I mean he seemed so proud of you you
guys seemed so in love what was he
saying to you when you guys went home at
the end of the night how was he feeling
it was I mean we both kind of deal with
things the same you know were the
youngest so he likes to let things well
and he also likes to hear my side and
you know what I have to say about it so
he just kind of likes that back and
listen to everything I had to say and
just like taking what I was you know
dealing what I'm going through and you
know just say things that would make me
feel good and also you know say real
things so that's kind of how he you know
takes things and you know just like
gives me the input that I need yeah well
I mean and you went through so much on
the show so many ups and downs actually
a Lea Michele just said that she was so
frustrated to see you go home that you
should have won how did you feel hearing
that it was good you know
it's nice that we support each other
constantly throughout you know the last
six or seven years even being off the
show it's it's good to hear that she's
still supporting who are you in touch
with the most these days through so
closest with from the gleek yeah well
i'm kevin was there at the show with us
which was so great and also obviously
like very very sad as well as Michael
Hitchcock who was a writer on the show
and he's been Christopher Guest films
and stuff like that so I'm still close
to one of them and I'll sanaya you know
Diane I keep in touch a lot yeah and you
are you guys kind of bonding over the
mom thing now you have that in Korea
yeah yeah yeah yeah we've taken our kids
to you know the real world Park and just
we like to keep in touch and just like
you know talk about things going on in
our lives
okay had you heard from like did Leah
shoot you a text or anything or no no I
mean we're so busy like you know I
understand you know she has all these
things going on she's doing her new
album and so you know she's keeping busy
with that part of her life so well I
love seeing the Glee people on Dancing
with the Stars because you guys have so
much stage presence already I mean again
you just killed it on the show um we
watched you go through this journey with
Alan and Max yes who are you still
talking to more now Alan or max I mean
people talk about how you get so close
with your partner and you kind of spent
almost equal time it seems as both of
them
yes you
I think Alan and I because he's so young
and so like you know excited and eager
we was talked about how he was like a
little puppy which he knows so I'm not
saying something that he has no idea
we're talking about but he you know he's
checking in and constantly making sure
I'm okay and he's like I miss you and so
you know they really become a part of
your family or you're constantly like
checking in with Max and Alan and saying
you know it's am i okay or they're
always just making sure that you're
comfortable which is like a weird a
weird experience you know Elizabeth
Hurley reached out to me and she was
just like you know telling me how she
felt and she was sorry that I got kicked
off the show but she also was just like
it's such a roller coaster because you
get close to these people that are kind
of a part of your family and then you
kind of lose them and it's like it's
very bizarre you know you kind of have
to like adjust like yeah they're not
really my family and anymore so that's
like that's kind of the weird like
adjustment period that you go through
afterwards yeah well and I think max in
one of our interviews had said something
like this might not be the last you'll
see of us could we see you and max
dancing together again I know the
Dancing with the Stars tour was just
announced yeah I think I mean I hope so
we've talked about it and I would
personally love to so I'm not against it
and I would really love to you know just
dance on on the stage with him one more
time because we only had two two shows
where we got to actually dance together
which is really disappointing it is
disappointing but you killed it in the
numbers that you had and we talked a lot
too about how man Alan was so great with
you we we kind of started a hashtag Alan
for pro I think he deserves to be one we
all know this to be one Mac said it and
we need to say it again like he deserves
to be a pro yes so professional and he's
just so like funny and you know I think
he is just somebody that we all need to
see on that stage every week did this
show I mean I'm not sure how much you
I'm obviously your background was in
dancing but I'm not sure how much you
had been dancing right before you'd gone
on the show did it renew a love for
dancing for you in any way I mean just
to be like rehearsing every day again or
how much had you been doing yeah it's
good I wasn't a lot you know and I was
like I had dabbled a little bit and
going to classes and just you know
trying to just you know feel good about
myself and doing dance again but it kind
of was just that feeling of what I grew
up with and what makes me feel good you
know like every week dancing is
that can endorphin builder so that alone
is outstanding but just getting to be
performing and doing what I love that
was like that was really really nice to
do every week you know get to do things
and show people what I am and what I've
done and grown up doing yeah I mean as
someone who had previously danced with
Beyonce I mean you've done some really
cool things how would you compare the
level of training and rehearsing you had
done in other situations for other jobs
- Dancing with the Stars because people
talk about just how intense but you know
is it's it's hard it's it's really
challenging it's a lot likely you know
you're you're not only doing just the
dancing aspect of it you're not going to
rehearsals you're also like having to go
into the studio and you know do
interviews and do extra press and you
know just all the things that people
don't really know go into it it's
there's a lot and it's like you know
it's kind of time consuming but when you
have end result it's really magical and
powerful
what's more intense training for Dancing
with the Stars or rehearsing and
training with Beyonce I mean when I was
doing Beyonce I was young and so it was
like so easy for me to just like be in
the studio for 12 hours and be okay and
be like I'm gonna eat a big sandwich and
some chips and then huh whereas now it's
like I'll dance for a day and it takes
me like a day to like recover and just
like not be old oh my god you're being a
little hard on your self acknowledged I
think I'm a me yeah your trust me you're
in great yeah also I feel like Max is a
hard partner to have even Alan said like
Max is hard on harder on celebrities
than he is I mean I can't I couldn't
stop thinking about that um rehearsal
moment on the episode when you were
eliminated when he was trying to show
you that lift and you're like what is
this he's like I'm making it up yeah
yeah yeah it was fine in the end like I
was like oh this is so much easier but
in actuality Alan was a lot tougher of a
choreographer than next was I mean max
he's been doing it for so long so he was
just really like okay whatever makes you
feel comfortable if you need to relax go
relax and I think he could just kind of
tell you know when I needed to take
breaks for it like Alan he wanted to
make sure it was good and perfect so he
really just made sure to like rehearse
it as much as we could so that it was in
my body and that I felt as comfortable
as I could so in the end I think I think
Alan being ended up being a harder
teacher than
interesting life to tell Alan that Alan
you need to judge yourself better you're
the tough one it's already so many
comments is coming and saying that you
should not have gotten eliminated that
you were the best answer this season she
literally got the first perfect score
and a lot of those Heather you should
have stayed not fair
Edward wants to know Heather which is
harder which do you find more of a
challenge singing or dancing mmm I think
singing is very very hard to do
especially they're going to do it live
for me I grew up singing but I also was
it was not my like number one so you
know singing in a studio where people
are just kind of like only listening to
you in their headphones like that's it's
hard to adjust to so I think I think
singing was more of an adjustment period
for me than dancing good and Lolly says
if they do a Dancing with the Stars all
stars would you accept mmm I don't know
I think we're going to take a poll on
that I think we'll take a poll and see
how the viewers feel what's making you
not say yes right away I know I would do
it and I would be happy to you know get
to performing and that would be awesome
but it is time-consuming and you know
it's it's a hard thing to try and you
know balance if you're going to do I
also like to pursue acting and I'm
really vigilant in that and I want to
make sure that that's something that I
like to take a part of so I don't know I
think it would have to depend on the
moment and you know where I'm at and
what I'm doing okay fair enough Sarah it
is time commitment though keywords but
Don is asking what I did want to get
into with you and then what so many
people had talked talked about do you
think that you were pre judged or judged
differently more harshly at all because
of your dance background which is
something a lot of people talked about
with you the seasons yeah I think when
you're watching the show you see that
they have to kind of be careful and take
care of each person on their own to what
their dance ability is and it's also you
know they're constantly reminding us
like hey you know you've made this kind
of growth and you know you have gone
from A to B in this journey and I think
a lot of people like to see that when
they're watching the show because they
can really relate so I do know that that
you know they're obviously harsher on me
because I am a dancer and that's fine
you know I accepted it I knew that in
the beginning and I wasn't ever like
holding a grudge and you know it was I
understood what
going on yeah I mean again you were so I
mean we've had Sharna in here before and
she's talked about how she tells her
partner's to just be quiet and just
listen to the judges she's like don't
say anything back it's too dangerous
don't do it no you were so graceful when
you took the judges criticism and God
something I felt like Len was so hard on
you I really was like Len calm down as a
viewer when you were standing there who
was the one who you were maybe nervous
to hear their criticism or which judge
did you listen to more like how did you
relate to each of them that was maybe
the most nervous about Julianne I think
I didn't really know which way she was
going to go each week you know I didn't
know if she was going to be like I loved
it or you know well you could have done
this wrong I think she was just like
somebody that kind of just played it
week by week and watched each show
separately you know as their own as
their own being so I kind of you know
every week I was like oh my god what is
she going to say I don't really know it
was just a wild card yeah it was a wild
card but I was like what you know when
he let me always is like either man and
love it or content yeah content I didn't
love hip-hop I mean yeah what advice
would you give someone now I mean just
anybody going into the show now that
you've gone through it and also
especially somebody who maybe does have
that dance background like you have I
mean would you have done anything
differently looking back now about your
time image I don't I think it's
important to be yourself and really be
genuine to you know how you feel about
all the circumstances you know if you
don't feel comfortable you know doing
this or whatever I just I feel like it
was a good journey and it's it's
whatever was meant to happen happened
and as corny as that is it's really true
it's like you know you go through
anything in life and you come out the
other end years later or weeks later
knowing that it helped you in a certain
way or I taught you a lesson so I think
anybody doing that you can't really
prepare for something like this you know
it's just such a big it's a big on
picking but it's it's it's positive and
it's like whatever happens happens I
think people need to know that did it
surprise you was it what you expected it
to be the whole experience it wasn't it
was like it was so much more you know it
was there was so much more to it than I
thought it was going to be you know I
was like I was gonna be dancing it's
fine you know it's going to be hard and
I used to dancing anymore' like I was
when you know
I was starting out but I'll get used to
it I'll figure it out and it ended up
being a lot more than that anything that
you wish you could have done like last
night was movie theme any now he really
kind of wish you could have gotten your
teeth around I wanted to do contemporary
very bad I thought it would have been
fun it would have been very hard and had
I had gotten it when Mandy Moore was on
I would have died and been awful and she
would have critiqued me so bad No yeah
so that was the only one that I just was
like oh man
I missed out but that's okay it was cool
to see her on the judges it was even
last night here on the judge oh my gosh
it was so great everything she said was
just like on point and phenomenal was
that I mean you having that dance
background were you yeah she's kind of I
mean we're all starting to know her as
the public from lala land but is she
sort of legendary in the dance world as
a quarry on
in a good way you know she's worked hard
for what she wants and it's showed I
mean it's taken her a long time it's not
like it happened overnight so you know
seeing her up there was just really
really fantastic she was yeah it was
perfect to see her there and it felt
like the whole group like Tom and Aaron
everybody were so excited to see her
there yeah people talk so much about how
the show is like a family did you have
that experience did you many everybody
last night I did yeah it's like it's
weird you make such a great relationship
with all these people and you know like
they're all just kind of your your
day-to-day even though you don't see
them the entire week at that Monday and
that Sunday you're kind of just like how
I look forward to seeing you every day
and so it's just that camaraderie and
getting to know everybody that's that's
the thing that you miss yeah Allen says
you should have your own dance reality
show okay would you do more reality TV
anything that you would consider
anything that's been offered - um I I
mean it it would be nice because you can
make your own schedule in a way but you
know I I would do some sort of dancing I
mean Dance Moms come on like everybody
loves Dance Moms and a buzz into Dance
Moms like who doesn't but you know
anything that has to do with me I think
you know it would it would be something
I have to consider and you know talk
about with my husband and just kind of
like figure out that's right for me or
you know what I want
you said you're a reality TV watcher
what are your what are some of your
guilty polka there's just so many I'm
obsessed with Keeping Up with the
Kardashians like any
as for the fan of Minos I love them I
love them to death oh you bet them I
have not no no I don't think I want to I
think I would be like don't have you
here oh yeah yeah yeah you know Kourtney
is just fantastic or whatever I know
she's a great person like I'll leave it
at that and you know my husband watches
a lot of Discovery Channel and like
naked and afraid' and like all those
things that are just like I would never
do that in my life like yeah that's
insane good for you like mm-hmm you know
mine does too and we've thought about
like would we go on a couple's version
of naked and afraid I'm like now we
would kill each other and eat each other
that's how we would survive because yeah
I think you have to go into that with a
stranger and we polite enough to not
yeah exactly that's why I don't have to
be polite and say like okay good just to
the situation yeah and some people
aren't like some people are like I don't
like you like I just were there moments
when you I mean did you have to be
conscious on Dancing with the Stars
about you seem like a very calm person
but you know Cameron who is our other
host who's been here before he's the
nicest guy and he's like one time they
caught me in one little freakout and
then that was the whole package yeah
were you very cognizant about very very
cognizant yeah there's no way it was
like no no no I'll save the drama for
like my own personal life
no no but and that's that's the give or
take it's like you know people that
watch the show want to see that and
that's that's the moments that they look
forward to but you know that's something
that I personally don't I don't want to
be a part of who I am so it was just me
that I was like let's take care of this
on our own time if I have any problems
like we'll figure it out but yeah let's
just be professional on set and you know
leave the drama for elsewhere was it
hard to do that with max he's very
intense no Max and I are like Max is Max
and I were very eye to eye on things
like if we had anything to talk about we
figured it out so yeah that was it was
really really helpful helpful for him to
be there you guys vibed yeah yeah did
you miss him when he was gone yes I did
you know it was weird I only got to be
with him for two weeks but it was also
like we were friends and I knew he was
taking care of himself and getting
better so it was I was understanding
about have you talked to him recently is
he a hundred percent healed or I mean I
don't even know if he can do this fast
but I mean when I was working with him
last week he seemed like he was
I kept checking on him like hey is your
leg okay like do you feel comfortable
with what you know are you okay and he
was just like no I'm fine like it's
weird I feel great and yeah I know she
he said he was shaky but other than that
like he was just great again at a la
loire Ali sorry I'm fencing announces
one week later after your elimination I
am still mad Edward wants to know what
was it like working with Beyonce I'm
sure you've never been asked this right
no she is great she was very
professional she comes in she does her
work and you know she's super busy she's
a lot of things going on in her life so
you know she she takes each piece of her
life and she she gives it everything and
that's how she works and it really
resonates with us like as you know at
her dancers we were very well aware of
it that she would come in and she would
do her work and then continue on to what
she needs to focus on so you know she
was very very professional now she's got
those twins coming oh my goodness to the
antigen which are you look can I ask do
you talk or think about more kids in the
future for you maybe we have talked
about it yeah we have no plans to have
any more kids I just love seeing your a
you know it's okay we've got a theme
kind of lasted about yeah because it's
underway it does it get discussed fairly
frequently is that the the laughter that
my manager and I talk about often of
just like two is enough it's comfortable
like you know Taylor always says like
one for each we're comfortable with one
for each taking care of it other than
that it's like it seems a little bit
overwhelming and applause to anybody who
does it because it's I'm sure it's like
insanely hard time I mean at least with
one for each you can tag team it a
little exactly yeah you take that one is
SS we're fine well I mean I don't have
kids I do think so much about I see my
friends who are working moms and it just
seems like already being a parent is the
hardest job in the world and then to be
a working mom I mean how do you balance
everything that you're doing with that
yeah it's like you have to find what you
you know your time frames of like you
know what I want to spend my time on and
also when you come home you don't want
to be working you don't want to be on
your phone you don't want to show your
kids that side of it and you know give
them the wrong idea of what I should be
doing with my time so when I'm home I
just really try to you know
take the time to be sitting with them
and play with them and play with Lego
and then just few things that like you
know make me happy as well as just like
have a really good family you know
dynamic I love that that was your most
memorable year with seeing your love
story and seeing your family and you and
your husband do seem just so in love
with each other what is it about your
relationship that really makes it work
for you and really knowing that he's the
one yeah I think we just knew it from
the beginning you know it's it's really
really corny to say that but we did we
knew and we still do and it's like even
just doing the show it was kind of like
a nice reminder and it kind of brought
us back to that that whole first year of
us dating of like that special like
spark we had and just you know like the
the dynamic we had when we started it's
like it's kind of being we brought it up
and now it's kind of like in us the last
couple weeks we've been together it's
just like every time I see them it's
kind of like that special moment because
I think we kind of brought it out on the
table which is like that's really really
nice I think a lot of couples should do
that more often is like celebrate you
know how you felt when you first got
together I love that so basically that
episode of the show kind of helped you
yeah it was very weird how we just had
that moment or like every time I see him
no it's kind of like I felt like I was
when I was 18 when we first started
dating how I'll do his are but yeah it's
fun so that's well thank you Dancing
with the Stars rekindling marriages I
love it
I want to make sure I'm not missing any
other fan questions for you
yeah just love coming in for you what do
you see is next for you I mean again
we'd love to see you on the Dancing with
the Stars tour but you mentioned acting
to where you kind of going from here
yeah so I have a good friend of mine her
name is Ashley and we have been writing
forever but we have our own web series
that we've been working on and we're
just trying to get out and you know get
people interested and just you know
really really work hard on that and make
sure it's it's a piece of us and like
you know what we want it to be so we're
really working hard in the web series
right now and you know just everything
writing I'm writing a dance script as
well that I've been working on forever
you know started about nine years ago of
just idea sparked in a movie or TV film
yeah and dancing home and it's great
it's like an indie film you know it
incorporates acting and
and I'm really trying to get julianne
hough interested so you know I'm trying
to work on it and and and iron it out so
that it's it's readable and she'll love
it and anybody else do you know anybody
I think it'll it'll really make a great
foam regardless of who's in it but yeah
that's kind of what my passion is right
now is working on that Oh somebody know
using so much writing I mean they say
write what you know and it sounds like
you're really writing that yeah cool
it's good to get it out and just is it
an unreadable story like from your own
real life is it is the movie inspired by
no it's actually inspired by some of my
good friends so weird to be writing
about some of my great friends but you
know there's such a part of my life that
it was just like I'm going to write down
these stories and what these people you
know what they've gone through and all
that stuff so awesome very cool you know
I'm just going back to the mom thing a
little bit but Peeta is a mom for the
first time and dancing on this season
did you and talk about that with her
give her any advice and I guess how did
you feel like doing this level of
intense dancing after your body having
gone through all that I just don't know
how she's doing it I would basically
were saying I can't believe she's doing
it like every week I was like what I
cannot believe that you are dancing this
intensely two months after you had a
baby like no way I was like lazy on the
couch like watching reality television
obviously I'm just like you know they
mean like good for her that's so awesome
and it's inspiring for a lot of people
oh my gosh I mean it's it's crazy and it
was she was so sweet it was so hard to
kind of we interviewed her after the
show and she was so upset to see you
guys go home because they knew how much
max wanted to be there yeah I think she
took it a little bit you know a little
bit more personally and then maybe maxed
it you know I think she was just like
she's there to support him and I think
it hit her pretty hard and then of
course we saw Peter go home last night
so you know let's go ahead and dive in
to last night's show
we have the double elimination PETA and
went home of course and then Nancy and
Artem were you surprised
well so I just I literally just found
out I I go to bed at like nine o'clock
like let's be real I'm an old lady and I
do you had you thinking why you can call
yourself old this is I am now my
husband's joke seems like you are old
your he called me
old grumpy old lady grumpy pants because
I know that's not you yeah so I was just
somebody just told me about the news
this morning I didn't know that both of
them had gotten kicked off I was
surprised to see I think you know Nick
and PETA in their package last night had
even said that they were dancing with
the latter Alan yes oh you're like
you're watching I'm like there's no way
this is going to be the last time you
know what I mean like for me it set it
up like okay they might have immunity
like I didn't quite know interesting you
guys please let us know what you thought
of Nick and PETA and advancing Artem
getting sent home want to know if you
were as surprised as Heather I was
surprised by Nancy and Artem because she
is getting such great inconsistency
hours every week does that just mean
that it speaks to how important the fan
vote is were you surprised by how
important the fan vote does ultimately
seem to be in all this I am you know you
don't really know and you're also
working really hard to get the word out
and just do your own like you know
instagramming and all that stuff because
it's really important but there's also a
lot of people out there who aren't a
part of social media and who just wants
to show for what it is and so I think
voting is a really big part of it yeah
yeah I mean my grandmother has never
even seen a Facebook page but she
watches the ocean your eyes yeah she
knows what's up yeah
surprising it is a it's again I think
Nick you know Nick had said he kind of
felt like it but I think it was also
painful to watch Nancy go home because
she loves the show so much and she
really worked hard and everything should
oh my god I mean I'm really that level
on an Olympic level so true who did you
wind up being closest with in terms of
the other celebrity competitors who
you'll you'll maybe still maintain a
relationship with from here yeah I am I
did you two know Nancy very well I think
in the beginning we bonded I just like I
knew she was and I was like oh my god
Nancy like hey Heather but we also had
kids and it was like you know we just
kind of talked at first you know about
our families and stuff like that and I
think Simone also is something that like
kind of I I stuck close with in the end
sort of just because we're we did that
whole group dynamic and she's just funny
and she's you know she's young and she's
just like really you know she's amazing
at what she does but she also is like
excited to be there and just one
to learn about you know anything so yeah
I went to one of her rehearsals with
Sasha and she's so innocent you know you
see how she is funny she keeps talking
about the sexy thing and you do you see
she would move us on gymnastics for so
long and now she's kind of discovering
and dating and and thinking Rashad as
hot as we all do
all right so going through the dances
last night Bonner and Sharna I know
Sharna has said she is surprised that
they are still in it at this point and I
think Bonner is kind of tied into their
daily well here it is they did a
western-themed of course it was movie
night so Western perfect for cowboy
Bonner are you watching this and
thinking about what his body is going
through because I would imagine as a
dancer and athlete you have some
awareness of how hard this must be for
him at this right and I know in the
first couple weeks she had even
mentioned about how he was like he was
super nervous about performing and it
was really really hard for him but
watching him now like he just he looks
like he's having a really good time yeah
he's just like oh great oh my god I'm in
a cowboy movie there could have been a
more perfect thing for him he said it
was the dance II was the most excited
for out of all their dances yeah and I
do love how they keep giving him points
on you know his frame and kind of the
way heat because it seems like what he
is physically able to do he really is
trying I mean could you imagine though
like breaking your neck or whatever and
having go through that and then you're
on the you're on the stage of Dancing
with the Stars and you're like actually
doing kind of a good job like that's
good for him like that's fantastic yeah
and it was great to see you're so right
it was great to see the judges they
really gave him some good feedback okay
you know I think that they are at the
point where they're they are giving
critiques on those little kind of
pinpointed points but they're also like
a that was fun to watch
yeah so yeah yeah David and Lindsey so
David and Lindsey had sci-fi movie last
night and man talk about fun to watch
what are what's going through your head
when you want if you know David this is
the nicest person and he's just like
he's literally so nice like him and my
husband obviously bonded over baseball
because my husband was a baseball player
as well but he's just so friendly and
he's just like such a normal guy so it's
really great to keep you know keep
seeing him perform like this because
he's good at it a but also huge
a good guy so it's nice to see somebody
you know yeah out of their element you
know doing a great job and enjoying
every moment of it he's so lovable and
fun to watch and I love what a family
man he is his kids were in the audience
last night such a family man that's his
family I and he's talked about how the
him and Lindsay had to be kind of sexy
last week and I loved when he was like
well she's like she's my daughter or
something it's weird but yeah it was it
you know huge and again he I think they
gave him some notes again on kind of his
footwork or being flat-footed last night
which I don't really know what that
means what are they doin in there oh you
don't I don't I mean as a as a ballroom
dancer but I'm not I learned all these
different terms and I still don't I
still don't understand it and I don't
quite get it like when you when you have
to be on the ball of your foot and when
you don't and I don't know I just every
week I was just like okay okay what to
do and I'll do it that's fine like I
don't know what else I'm supposed to be
doing is that something that you felt
like people maybe didn't understand you
were going through because honestly as a
viewer I'm kind of thinking oh she has a
dance background social killed' at this
but was learning ballroom just a totally
new thing yeah it's like each week you
had to start over and start a new you
know each week it was something
completely different like rules that you
thought applied to whatever type of
dance you were doing
we're so irrelevant to the next week's
dance and you're just like okay well now
I got to do this and I got to learn this
like okay I'm a machine like let's just
keep going when he figured I had Nancy
and Artem sent home last night after
their danced a pretty woman it was a
pretty woman themed dance hmm I know
she's just so you know what she was
working so hard out there everybody has
said Artem did such a great job with her
how did you feel about their partnership
I thought they were great and he's such
like a calm you know cool collective
person and I think he really just kept
her grounded and they were so sweet
together I think it was so wonderful
moon dancing yeah Nick and Peeta this
was such a cool dance I thought they had
the spy film yeah that was fun yeah what
did you Dresden you did I did what y'all
have about it I thought it was I mean it
was so fun for him to play this part you
know like he loved it and it was
probably like a dream of his you know to
play a spy you know and I'm not in the
dance floor you probably never imagined
that but it was probably such a
feeling for him to do this so that's
probably really nice to go out with this
feeling of like he had mentioned that he
was having you know those that he was
dehydrated in his campaigns but he still
did a great job irregardless I think you
know it was something that he should be
proud of a lot of people who have been
in here have talked about how hard Nick
was working how much he wanted them of
the other celebrities and especially the
ones who are left who do you think is
working the hardest and wanting this the
most at this point I feel like we're
shod is working very very hard and he's
really putting a lot of his heart into
it and you can see it you can watch it
when he's you know doing that that video
heated last night with Emma like they
really wrote there right he literally
wrote the story like what happened I
went home and I did my homework like
look who is this guy
so you can tell each week the weather
he's practicing where he just puts
everything into it and you know that's
that's special and that's important yeah
norm on e and Val we have up next and I
mean she finally got that ten from Len
yeah I have to say I loved watching her
how did you feel watching the dance I
didn't see this oh he didn't see us my
turn in a fun she I told you I went to
midnight oh yes okay you made it about
what halfway through yep I made a half
okay well she finally got a 10 from Len
very excited to get that and the judges
all gave her tons of praise Mandy Moore
talked about how her legs have gotten
much stronger and her leg work is just
unbelievable yeah their theme was
foreign films and I do think she's a
great performer you know you see it in
her face and did you feel like she was
your biggest competition when we'd been
doing our recaps every week a lot of
people had said like Heather normanni
they're both so good how did you feel in
terms of who your competition was yeah I
feel like she's such a wonderful dancer
and she's very strong so I never looked
at her as a competitor but as a dancer
you know you're like she's doing a
really really great job and she's
working really really hard especially
because she was going overseas for like
four weeks which was crazy and she's
young and so you know I just wanted to
make sure like most of time I was like
are you okay like take care of yourself
and she had her mom there to help her
but um she works really hard and you can
tell she she's dancing her aass off and
I'm along so I can't say that word
she is she's in it to win it most the
time and she's really putting a lot of
effort into it she did have a little bit
of an injury last night they showed the
back problems are back I didn't fully
understand it if I'm being honest but
yeah it was something with her her back
was bothering her and she had to again
some meds for but then she kind of like
danced through the video hopefully that
won't affect her and run out you talked
about Rashad Rashad and Emma man it was
so fun to watch him did you see this one
oh yeah I was this one I mean his eyes
everything about there tell me what you
loved about it was ready from the moment
he got out of that that coffin he was
just like I am in it look at his eyes
he's just like oh my god I'm living this
is fantastic and Emma is just like a
powerhouse every time you watch her and
she's such a sweet person to like and
you know she she's always there with you
she's always just like you know she's
having a real conversation with you and
so their partnership is just like I
think it's really magical I'm having so
much fun I know they gave him one you
know just like a child that's like I am
living out my fantasy like I am doing
everything I want to do I mean I again
they say with athletes they have that
drive in that I mean he really daily
focused he really does yeah I worked
really hard you know even when we were
we were not rolling her we were not
doing anything and everybody went to go
we they were the last people in the
ballroom still working hard and so that
really makes that makes an impact on not
only you know their performance but I
think all of us like you can just see it
I feel like you think Rashad is going to
win what I'm not going to say it out
loud she said it who just works really
hard
okay that's important you know to see
somebody working so hard and you know we
want to see him succeed and not only
football but everything else that he's
putting his his heart into you know I
interviewed him about a week ago and was
talking to him about the dating thing
because he's like I would imagine
getting a lot of offers now that he's on
the show especially but he was like I'm
just so focused on everything got to do
I'm very single like yeah okay he's very
focused and it is it's unbelievable the
last couple last night with Simone and
Sasha and they had the silent film theme
they did kind of a fun Charleston
I loved it you did it was adorable I
mean she was so cute well you know
considering that kind of the feedback
they've given her is you need to be a
little more national this was almost a
perfect dance / I thought because this
dance really is just about kind of
plastering a smile on it'll be
interesting to see because Sasha and
Emma are engaged if they end up in the
final together right right right right
right well they're always so
professional like you know are all of
them like PETA and and Max are just like
there's never any you know there's never
any animosity or anything but like you
know I I think they just try and keep it
as professional as they can I do wonder
what the conversations are like at home
right did they talk about is there
something like you know like something
that sparks and I just like I'm so mad
today yeah who do you see going to the
top three at this point I think my top
three picks personally is Rashad for
sure I would love to seen Armani on
there and I think number three can
really be a wild card I mean we'd all
love to see David and the top three
because come on who doesn't love David
Ross he's fantastic and he you know
helps when they're in win the World
Series but I think number three of the
wild card Simone works really hard she's
also a great dancer so I think we just
really you know we don't know are those
your top three who you want to see or
who you think you'll see based on
knowing what you know I think everybody
wants to see you know those four you
know in the end I really you know it's
weird to see me in' to go home cause
she's such a great dancer it's funny you
say that his comments are coming in
Jessica says I want a Nancy to say I
loved how is Bonner still there and
Carmen says Nancy shouldn't have gone
home it is I mean I don't know his
Bonner getting those good-looking guy
votes he's such a sweetheart too I don't
know yeah he's such a nice guy yeah he
didn't anybody over the show we don't
know that okay I have no idea okay
it's we didn't know you didn't know I'm
not going to tell him well they played
up that storyline of the Bonner sharnid
Kevin right for a little while and I
mean if any plenty of girls going after
him now like yes I mean he'll happy by
when he's done he'll be mine him and
Rashad can go out together he can
encourage Rashad to actually date
someone I mean I couldn't believe when
I'm talking to the guy Sean needs a nice
girl you know what he told me he means
he said he needs a woman who wants to
leave a legacy good lord
okay standards are hyper
please a lot of pressure I know but he
was such a sweetheart I want to make
sure I don't have any other questions
for you and thank you again for being
here yeah I don't I mean it's just again
we all were so sad to see you go but
it'll be so interesting to see where
things go
from here so you think Rashad is going
to win I think it's a toss-up we'll see
you never knew honestly never know I
mean whatever has been going on you know
it started with I was sad to see Erika
Jayne go personally I mean I'm a huge
fan of her anyways but it was really
hard to see her go because she's a great
dancer and you want to keep seeing her
perform you just really never know in
the end what what's going to happen well
it is a little crazy to see how things
have worked out because before the
season started so many people were
telling us that they felt like overall
it was a really strong season of female
competitors you know believing you and
romani and Simone has an Olympian and
Erika Jayne who is a performer so it
seemed like such a strong group of women
but now in the end it's winding up with
three guys and and it's more guys than I
was really so it is quite surprising
yeah yeah I don't know how does that
make you feel are you a little
frustrated like wishing no I think it's
you know it's a testament to say yeah
the votes do matter because a lot of
people are voting for you know who they
want to see and I think that's important
I think people need to take that to
heart and really say hey I need to go
and vote
you know David Ross and yeah all the
latter it's like you just really need to
go and vote for who you want what advice
would you give the people who are left
at this point if you could maybe text
them or tell them here's what you need
to do to make it to the final I don't
know I think everybody's just doing such
a great job I think everybody is just
really happy and working really hard at
this point the level of talent and the
personality is it's all good
Thanks everybody's just at great great
at what they do yeah it's fun to watch
again people love coming in for you
sherry just says Heather I love you and
you deserve to have stayed Dianna wants
to know can we see you return for any
other episodes will you make an
appearance in the finale yes yes I will
be back to the finale which will be
great I'll be nice to see everybody
again and then excited to see what they
do do you know yet any idea no idea and
that's true I have no is going on the
finale I just know I'm there and I get
to you know see everybody again
c-max and Alan and yeah awesome
how does your little one feel about you
doing the show today like oh my god I
loved it they loved it it was every week
he was just like mom I'm going to see
you dancing on the Stars or like he in
the middle of class one of his teachers
came to me and was like he just like
stopped in the middle everything and he
was like did you know my mom's dancing
on in the star or on the stars or
something like that it's like that's
adorable like he loved it he thought it
was so fun
oh and like Disney making out to me all
the characters which like for us that
was so exciting because if you don't
have a three-year-old you don't
understand like meeting those big huge
characters with those giant heads on is
like really really scary so you know
like you just don't bring them around
you know and you've never introduced
them because they're just going to be
scared as hell but he nuts he met them
and he was actually like giving them
high-fives and playing with them so my
husband and I were like oh my god like
this is great like it was it was perfect
to have him there that week you don't
have to take him to Disneyland no I've
you said that the show every last
question but you said the show made you
think about your marriage a little bit
differently because you were kind of
considering it did it make you think at
all differently about being a mom or
kind of incident really it really you
know made me enjoy the times when I was
with them and really take it take it for
what it was and you know enjoy that time
and not take it for granted because you
know we were working long hours and so
it was nice to go home and be with them
and take those special moments
awesome well so glad to learn you're
going to be in the finale guys thank you
so much for watching of course we're
here every Tuesday recapping the show so
like et on Facebook make sure to follow
Heather on social media and hopefully
that movie happens it sounds like you'll
be asked them yeah Lee and have to do it
anybody it's fine it's fine I'm just
excited to get it out and get it written
and have everybody see you know what
kind of vision I have for it awesome
thank you guys so much for watching and
have a great day everybody
[Music]
you